it's happening to you again
why do you think that this is repeatedly
happening to you why do you think
they chose you
how far down the rabbit hole do you want
to go as deep as we can okay
so um
in order to tell that i got to tell
another story ahead of time the story of
march 10th 2013
which is it's easy to find online on the
presentations i talk about it it's an
event that happened in the desert of
of uh southern utah
let's take this to tell this correctly
takes about take some time so i'll
i can i don't want to give you just the
surface story but i'm going to try to
race through it a little bit okay
well we have we have uh
five and a half hours how your plane
leaves okay
so i was at a ufo conference and i
um was driving home the ufo conference
was in southern arizona i lived in idaho
you draw a line the travel line of
travel is right through utah
and i love utah so i wanted to take
these little back roads and twisty turny
roads through like the
through the four corners area through
like the national parks through the the
sandstone desert you know where like
they shot the
like the location for the roadrunner
cartoons you know that terrain
which i love and i did a lot of outdoor
work over the years i've spent a lot of
time in that area and i love it
so this is like it's deep respond to
that area
yeah you spent a lot of your life
outdoors camping and hiking
and teaching mountaineering in alaska
and in wyoming and all throughout the
rockies and in canada and
yeah and skiing in the winter so
so this is this is like this is just
another day for you this is what you're
used to this is your sport
so and then what happens is i'm totally
comfortable sleeping outside
sleeping under this which is another
crazy thing that's that's crazy sleeping
on a bed that's crazy when you think
about it you know like sleeping outside
with no tent
with [ __ ] bears and rattlesnakes and
that'll snakes are asleep at night
rattlesnakes don't come at night the
bears are like
you know i've so i've slept on
yellowstone anyway so yes i've so for me
it's
what's what's a tent gonna do if the
bear comes along like how's that gonna
slow him down
that's true might slow rattlesnake down
but um
but uh so at this point in my life
2010 i've got the blog i'm i'm going to
ufo conferences i'm
completely immersed in this stuff i've
got a podcast
um and
driving home from the ufo conference it
was a spot i knew i'd driven these roads
before and i was like you know
leave here in the morning i bet you i
sleep at this spot on highway 20.
i bet you i sleep there i drove over
there years ago and i said this would be
a good place to sleep
so i'm like i'm going to aim for that
that's where i want to sleep tonight
so i i uh
sun's going down it's march which is
kind of wintry still so it's cold at
night in the desert
that time of year cold at night so i
pull into this little turnout
and i um
lay my sleeping bag down in the dust i
got a great big winter sleeping bag i
got my pillow that i drive with i've got
a pad a big thick pad
right next to my car the turn out was
great like there's a spot i could
there's a little sort of dirt road and
there were some
places where other people had obviously
parked there and there's some old
campfire rings and stuff people had been
there so it's a it's a it's not just
like a random spot there's obviously a
place that other people can go
yeah and it's like a little it's a dirt
road and stuff like that it accesses
another dirt road and stuff like that so
it's a spot that
in this to out west is pretty normal
okay you get tired
right just pull off to the side of the
road and sleep on the ground you don't
do that in florida it's way too [ __ ]
hot and humid
yeah yeah so this is like this is
there's no humidity zero humidity right
and everyone's mormon so everyone's like
if like that's like uh
everyone's nice so so uh
so i'm sleeping on so i lay down to go
to sleep and i wake up and i look up on
this hillside
and i say that looks just like a landed
flying saucer
there's a sting up on this hillside it's
this big round structure and i look up
and i go
that looks just like a landed flying
saucer i think to myself
and um i've got do you want yes
pictures you know what here let me do
one thing here like can we edit this out
or you could we can put this
no let's put it in so so um go to my
website
the search bar and then just scroll down
a little bit oops
and just keep on scrolling because i
actually have a bunch of pictures that
are all on one just
keep no no um i won't oh hey let's try
um
i i don't know that i don't wouldn't
know the title of it just scroll down
it's been within the last
year or so just keep go fast just go
buzz past everything oh no
you're on the old page there so just hit
the top the the go all the way back up
to the top and hit the logo at the top
go to the home page reboot it yeah
reboot the home page
great yeah you can just go go
yeah it's going to be just really you
might even have to go to the next page
but this is going to be easier for me to
find it
yeah keep on going just go all the way
down i'll see when it shows up keep on
going down yeah great
that go to older posts older posts down
yeah they go yeah
and then there's an owl i saw in the
backyard for those uh
listening and not watching we are
scrolling through um
hold up there you go there we go here
you go there so now the all these
pictures are
are from the march 10th story so i've
talked about it on a on an
audio book okay and so so go ahead so
there's the turn off
okay so that's where you were camping
that's right camping that's a that's a
google maps view i kind of
i'm an illustrator so i tooled that a
little bit and that arrow nighttime i
made it i was a daytime picture i made
at nighttime yeah so
so go ahead so click double click that
image there with the thing so i look up
on this hillside
and there's this round building up there
and i say that looks just like a landed
flying saucer
and i look at this thing and i'm like
thinking like like i'm
like just at a ufo conference and i like
like if this was a ufo this is a landed
flying cell so i should feel something
and
at my gut level i should feel something
like intuitively i should feel something
right
and i looked at this thing i felt
nothing at all i rolled over and went to
sleep
i woke up a second time and there was a
coyote
howling near my head now i've slept
outside
a thousand nights in terrain like this
and i've heard a lot of coyotes i have
never
heard anything that close i sat up i
looked around i couldn't see it
surrounded by safety coyotes ever [ __ ]
with you no they might
no i've never heard anyone do kaizo mess
people they're scared of them
uh i mean anything's possible right so
yeah i mean they could get into food or
something like that right so
but uh so anyway but i was not scared at
all it was like this magic moment
like i'm in this beautiful spot there's
a trillion stars that's
absolutely like night in the desert is
unlike anything else
like it's way out in the middle of
southern utah no light pollution from
anywhere
so like this coyotes howling i look up
and that thing is still there
and there was actually one little light
off to the side which i you can see
there's one light that's not really
connected
and i remember thinking like you know
what that's like that's like at my house
at home like that's the lawn light
you know like i'm in front of this house
so i rolled over and went back to sleep
and
i woke up a third time and there's a
bush near my feet and there was this
bright
light behind the bush and it was like
this weird light it wasn't a car
headlight it wasn't someone with a
flashlight it was this weird light
it seemed white but it it wasn't like a
like a car like you open a car door and
the dome
light wasn't it wasn't headlights it was
like something
i was like okay someone else is sleeping
here tonight someone just pulled in and
they're sleeping here
and i looked up at that thing and was
still up there on the hilltop and i
rolled over and went back to bed now the
next morning i woke up
and i i don't remember if i looked up to
see this
building on the hillside it was dark
when i got up still i like felt like i
slept all night i
kind of go to bed early when you're
driving and then i drove home it was
about a
12 hour drive or so from that from there
so 10 hours or so so from that spot
early in the morning like five in the
morning i start driving i get home in
the afternoon to my house in idaho
and the first thing i do when i get home
is i look up on google maps thinking
like oh there should be a
there should be a building there
building there so go ahead and scroll
down a little bit
all right so there should be a building
there and i i went back a year later
yeah okay there's there's like that's
google maps and i kind of put the little
uh
there's my sleeping spot with the yellow
push bin and there's the spot i went
back later so a year later i went back
there there's no building up there
and that was too poke and i don't go too
much farther yeah so
so that building there or excuse me that
um that hillside there is the hillside
without anything there i went there full
daylight that was your that was your
perspective from where you were sleeping
standing in the exhaust make that
picture big jordan yeah right there so
it looks like
it looks like you know sagebrush
wilderness of you know cattle country in
southern utah that's the whole
that's what looks like that and that is
exactly i'm very very skilled with maps
so that's exactly yeah yeah as a as an
outdoor educator yeah okay so i'm good
and i make maps and so go up one
you have to and then
yeah so there's that's google maps so
that was so i i used photoshop and i put
that arrow in and i put the little fake
dots up there to show where the round
structure was that is from the sleeping
spot it's
2.6 i think it's 2.6 miles away which in
the desert
is you're crystal clear right there's no
humidity in the air
so so i've i know i've gone to my like
i've looked at homes 2.6 miles away
on a hillsides and i've measured on maps
and you can see a house you can totally
see the roof and see the house in the
garage and everything like that
so um but it wasn't there
which i sort of knew i that was but and
the moment when i looked up on the map i
was like why wasn't that there maybe the
map was
maybe the new building is brand new and
the map is only a year old right
so i made a blog post and that's what i
did the illustration for
for a blog post so i posted that blog
post this is where it gets weird now
that blog post i posted at 12 34 1 2 3
4.
okay it's a little kernel of information
if you go back in my blog and
shortly after march 10th there's the
blog that where i write about it real
time
slept out in the desert saw this weird
thing heard coyotes light at the foot of
my bed
and then
uh after i post it i actually called
mufon
said have you had any reports from this
area this guy
said not from that last night would have
been the night before right not from
last night but we get a lot of reports
in that area yeah
so so go down one and there's a little
map there so i'm standing
just click that once so i'm standing at
the side of my
desk after posting this thing and now
just you gotta trust me on this one
because there's no one just
me like you gotta i
i standing inside of my desk i had this
like one second click
psychic flash i see in my mind's eye
this map
i see that in my mind's eye
and then it just is there for a second
and it disappears and i've got my
computer open
i was just looking at maps i got all
these points i got the point the yellow
point there is where the greenish point
there is where i was
um sleeping sleeping and that's
that's uh what's the red dot that's
you'll find out
here to tell the story correctly uh so
i knew there were three events on this
three dots
on this thing so i knew what the green
one was
that was the event from the night before
right and i knew what the
blue one was that was an event from
doing this
from my head that was from the
springtime of
2010.
and i was camping with a friend of mine
natasha who i met at a ufo conference
she's from germany she came over to we
had a plan to spend time in the desert
and
hike around the four corners area that's
the four corners area that's where
colorado utah
new mexico and arizona all come together
that's a little spot where the state
lines cross there
so we had a great trip we spent we were
hiking
we just went for weeks we were hiking
around we had it was
great weather it was magical it was this
great trip
and we were pulled into the little town
of
cortes colorado and there's something
wrong with the breaks in my car
and so we're so i like asked someone on
the main street like is there a mechanic
and this guy says oh this guy is back
here he's good he's the town mechanic
everyone goes to him so i go to the
mechanic little teeny town
and i drop the car off and then natasha
and i just sit out front for 45 minutes
or something and
he comes out and it's it's like he's got
his oily rag
it's like a small town in dusty colorado
and he kind of looks at me and says
i can't let you leave town or you'll die
and i'm like what do you what what do
you mean by that he says well the brakes
are going to fail
the brakes are like the brakes if i i
would be liable if i let you out
with the car like this and it's like
okay what does this mean so i can fix it
but
it's going to be about five days until
the park comes in
it's like five days okay so the guy
at the shop helps me get a rent-a-car
natasha and i have nothing to do like
well like let's hang out for five days
so we'll leave the car here
we'll drive on a rent-a-car the rent car
was great it was easy it was cheap
little town you know so so that night we
camp on the side of the road we asked
someone where's good camping on the side
of the road around here
this girl the coffee shop she saw this
great spot you go take this thing out of
town you turn left here and there's a
forest service road
you'll find great stuff out there great
so we went out there we found great
stuff
set up a tent and
so natasha and i are sitting side by
side
and we woke up in the middle of the
night
screaming both of us were screaming
i have she describes it the same way i
do
i would i've since called it synthetic
fear
like it was i have spent thousands of
nights
in a tent i i've never felt anything
like this it was irrational fear
here go ahead and scroll up a little bit
so so i'm
i'm i i oh no down excuse me down
and just uh oops
oh i missed it it's not in there sorry
it's going to be out of order here i'll
find it in a little bit so
so i um uh
so i like natasha what happened what
happened what's going on what's going on
what's going on and i'm like
freaking out and she's like i saw a face
like saw face i don't know what that
means so face so we're screaming like
and i literally i felt like i climbed on
top of her like someone threw a hand
grenade in the tent like
what's going on why are we both so
scared
you can talk to natasha she'll she
says it the same way it was irrational
and then we just after a little bit
we're both asleep
we go from complete adrenaline freak out
to asleep
and then now this is work it's very
murky and i'm
only gonna this is i'm gonna tell you
what i remember i don't think this is
what happened but this is my memory
i had the total i'm shaking just telling
the story i had this elevator up feeling
and i floated off the sleeping pad
and i felt myself floating up and
through the roof of the tent
and i just kind of faded away just kind
of faded into this
whiteness this realm of total whiteness
and as i was floating i said
i have to remember this i have to
remember this i have to remember this
and then it changed to am i on a table
am i on a table
am i on a table now i have no memories
of being on a table
all i have is a memory is just this
totality of whiteness
so i don't know this is
all of a sudden i hear natasha's voice
which i don't think she said this i hear
natasha's voice with her german accent
she says mike you're floating and then
i'm back in the tent and i'm
and she so we both sleep soundly
we wake up in the morning the birds are
chirping the sun's out
and i like natasha what happened last
night
and she's she's like i saw this face i
don't know
and so when i was floating i also saw
a round floating pizza pan
shaped disc which i've called a mandala
in in the tent with me
inside the tent it was inside the tent
so she i said where you know she said i
saw this face
and let's just to tell the story
properly it requires a lot i'm just
gonna
that's in the book i'll other i would
sidetrack
so i get out of the tent i walk around
and i'm like i'm like
like i'm literally looking for a spot on
the ground where a flying saucer landed
there's nothing there's no burn mark i
wanted to find it
right but later that day i found a
scratch on my chest it started at my
left shoulder and went almost to my
belly button
and it was in like it was a legit
scratch like a like a cat claw single
cat claws
red mark red line but when you looked at
it really closely it wasn't a scratch at
all
it wasn't like a wound like that at all
it was a it was a line of tiny
little fluid-filled blisters that were
kind of red
and what happened is a few days later it
washed off
like small dots almost like a small
line of polka dots each individual polka
dot was a tiny
fluid filled blister like like half a
millimeter
tiny and i needed glasses to see it and
when and i took a shower a few days
later and washed off
and and both natasha natasha's ufo
researcher in germany i'm a ufo
researcher here
when it washed off we both went we
should have taken a picture of it
that's another thing that's very common
people like avoiding pulling a camera
out
did you go and get a cat scan after this
no i didn't i never got a cat scan
so
i